a South Carolina coroner says too much
caffeine caused the death of a healthy
teenager 16 year old Davis cribe
collapsed last month at his high school
and died at a hospital he had consumed a
large soft drink a latte and an energy
drink over a short period of time
Tony de copal shows us how the boy's
parents hope their son's death is a
warning to others Tony good morning good
morning by all accounts this young man
was healthy and active and according to
his father he shunned drugs and alcohol
but a classmate who was with Davis cry
upon the day he died said he loaded up
on caffeine and in the classmates words
basically chugged an energy drink during
class Davis gripe was a high school
sophomore who found his rhythm while
playing the drums he was a great kid he
didn't get mixed up in the wrong things
he loved music or about their safety
their health especially once they start
driving but it wasn't a car crash that
took his life instead it was an energy
drink the 16 year old collapsed during
class last month and died at a hospital
while his initial autopsy required more
testing Richland County Coroner Gary
Watts said Davis consumed a large soft
drink a latte and then an energy drink
in less than a two-hour span bringing on
what he called a cardiac event these
drinks this amount of caffeine how its
ingested can have dire consequences and
that's what happened in this case you
know it when it happens you start to
feel dizzy you can feel it in your chest
CBS News medical contributor dr. David
agus says energy drink sent more than
20,000 people to the emergency room
annually the problem what we're learning
is that it's not just caffeine it's the
other stimulants that are in there and a
cup of coffee you may have over 45
minutes or 60 minutes these energy
drinks you're having all at once and so
all the caffeine gives this big peak in
the body and that's when bad things
happen
Sean Cripe says the tragic way his son
lost his life could be someone else's
lifesaver parents please talk to your
kids about the dangers of these energy
drinks the coroner said Davis's autopsy
showed no signs of a non founded or
undiagnosed heart condition the America
beverage Association which represents
the makers of almost all energy drinks
sold in America did not return a request
for comment the trade group says their
energy drinks can be safely consumed in
moderation Gail thank you very much Tony